[Music]
seems like a warrior battle crying
covered in blood and rushing towards an
enemy
the original idea behind chivalry is
capturing the fantasy of the medieval
hollywood movies and bringing that to
the hands of a gamer
being able to just live your fantasy of
being a knight or
carrying a sword i think that's why
people get really attached to it
the success of chivalry one blew us all
the way
it's been eight years since the first
game launched we always knew that we
were going to come back to chivalry too
we wanted to come back in a way that was
going to move the genre itself forward
our team now is comprised of industry
experts there's a lot more talent
there's a lot more ability
a lot more capability chivalry 2 is
going to feel
unlike any other fps out there we went
from the ground up
revisited what a melee combat game
should be and for us it's about
doing better than we did last time at
capturing three
we're a lot more focused on action and
group combat for chivalry too
we're adding a lot more moves and a lot
more control
as well the combat mechanics are
so polished and a lot of emphasis has
been put on making them accessible
without losing any of the complexity
we are refining and tuning animations
speeds damage defense almost
on a daily basis chivalry 2 is a lot
more dynamic
it allows you to be creative in a combat
zone
we have some traps that you can trigger
items that you can drive
like a wheel a bucket barrel
chickens our goal is to make it so it
feels like you're fighting for your life
this game takes the scale of the first
game and really raises it to 11.
battles are twice as big now 64 players
there's always going to be somebody
around you there's always going to be
these big team fights
it's not just the melee combat that was
felt in chivalry one
for us it was about we need enough
bodies to just
create the meat grinder machine needs to
run high enough for it to feel like
the chaos of war it's a real advancement
of everything the first game does it's
not just a chivalry 1.5 but
it truly is chivalry too our passion for
chivalry 2
is bottomless it's the game that started
the company
and it's the game that's going to take
us so much further
you're going to put your life on the
line you're going to go out there with a
couple inches of steel
it's a gritty fight to the end
there's a greatness in all of us that
can be reached
through fighting for a cause that's
greater than yourself
you